I want to start with a sincere
congratulations movies fantastic
um I have to start with an individual
question for you though because your
character is a big part of the comics
and I'm curious when you signed on did
Marvel pull you aside and say hey we
have plans or is it sort of like you're
gonna see as it goes Marvel doesn't tell
you anything nothing they don't tell you
anything
um yes uh this atuma is is very
different than the one that everyone has
seen in the comic books but there's also
its similarities to it you know
um as far as like what's gonna happen
no
I understand that I there every Marvel
person tells me the exact same thing for
both of you this is your first time
working on a Marvel production
especially a movie of this size and
scale for each of you what like
surprised you about making a Marvel
movie
everything everything it's a surprise
because well the training it's huge it's
not easy
maybe no it's it's
it's like a master class for me because
you need to focus on that
every every part in your character is
like we need we need training for for
stream underwater for ACT underwater for
all the bread and you need to learn Maya
you need learn English you need to learn
a lot of things because we have a lot of
diversity in the movie so it's huge uh
work in a movie like this it's like oh
my God
I I need more hours in my day
I gotta think for me a point that was
very interesting uh on my on my very
first day the first person that I met
was Winston and one of the first things
that he said to me you know you're going
to read the script you're going to think
what you're doing you're going to think
what everything looks like by the
description of it but when you see it
it's a whole different thing so most of
the things that we shot was green screen
and you know I was like oh yeah this is
gonna look like this it's gonna look
like that but seeing the movie for the
first time it was just like
pretty different than what I had in mind
completes mind-blowing it's crazy what
they're able to do I'm a big fan of Ryan
and what he was able to do with bringing
in all these different characters adding
diversity dealing with what happened
with Chadwick I mean he really did an
exceptional job I'm curious as a
director what he's like on set when he
pulls you aside to give you direction is
it a few words how does he work with you
to get what he needs it's amazing he he
had an amazing energy because he
whispered all the time in your your
earrings is like hey Mabel what what do
you need I I want to feel comfortable
what is your experience experience as
Mexican woman as Latin American woman
for for bring namora some little things
and he try all the time to speak over
language you know he's he tried to learn
Spanish somewhat he tried to learn some
my Awards and it's amazing because you
you can you can find a lot of complicity
in with with your director you know
for me it was it was such an amazing
experience because he brings the
humanity out of each character and
it was such a unique experience because
he finds a way to communicate with you
in your own language yes you know I'll
give you an example I'm a huge
basketball fan in one of our meetings we
start we started talking about
basketball and a lot of the times when
he was giving me directions you know he
would use basketball analogies and that
to me was like ah you you're talking
like to me like just like right here
this is a conversation and for him to do
that I was just like wow I'm I'm very
honored that that you're taking this
approach to just communicate with me
so it was it was the most amazing
experience and not every director you
know
that's why he's who he is I gotta go
congratulations on the movie it's going
to be a monster hit thank you so much